>> Dana: IT'S A FIGHT FOR
WORKING AMERICANS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SECURED IN 2016
AND I WAS LOOKING TO REGAIN
THEIR SUPPORT.
TURNING UP THE HEAT ON THE
DEMOCRATIC CONTENDERS IN
PENNSYLVANIA YESTERDAY.
>> WE WILL HAVE TO HIT
POCAHONTAS VERY HARD AGAIN IF
SHE DOES WIN BUT SHE STAGING A
LITTLE BIT OF A COMEBACK.
WHAT A GROUP.
POCAHONTAS AND SLEEPY JOE.
I DON'T THINK THEY GIVE A DAMN
ABOUT WESTERN PENNSYLVANIA.
>> YOU ARE THE ONES WHO WORK
HARD, PAY YOUR TAXES, BUILD YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND I DO HAVE A
FINDING OF A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO IS LOYAL TO
YOU.
>> Dana: DNC RESPONDING THIS
MORNING.
>> IT'S CLEAR DEMOCRATS STAND ON
THE SIDE OF WORKERS.
I THINK YOU SEE DEMOCRATS
TALKING ABOUT WANTING TO RAISE
WAGES.
SKILLS TRAINING.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW WERE
GOING TO FUEL THE ECONOMY.
POLLING SHOWS VOTERS ARE SICK OF
HIM TWEETING AND THE ATTACKS.
I THINK IF HE CONTINUES THAT,
DEMOCRATS WILL BE IN A STRONG
POSITION.
>> Dana: THIS COMES AS
JOE BIDEN'S FRONT RUNNER STATUS
MAY BE STARTING TO SLIP.
NEW NATIONAL POLL SHOWS
ELIZABETH WARREN IN A VIRTUAL
TIE WITH THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT.
AND NEW HAMPSHIRE THE NEW POLL
HAS BERNIE SANDERS BEATING
BIDEN.
IOWA AND NEW HAMPSHIRE, NOT
BUILT-IN ADVANTAGES FOR
JOE BIDEN.
SOUTH CAROLINA, HE HAS THE WALL
OF SUPPORT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE LOOKING AT ME
AS THOUGH YOU ARE ASKING A
QUESTION.
>> Dana: I WAS THINKING SHOULD
I ASK WRITING THIS QUESTION AND
THEN I WAS THINKING HE'S GOING
TO ASK WHY AM I ASKING THIS
QUESTION.
>> Greg: YESTERDAY WE TALKED
ABOUT TRUMP'S SUCCESS WITH SMALL
DONORS, IT REFLECTS GRASSROOTS
PASSION AND THE AVERAGE VOTER'S
PASSION FOR HIM.
WHO EXCEEDS HIM?
BERNIE.
SMALL DONORS BETWEEN 60% AND
70%.
HE IS THE GUY TO GALVANIZE THE
TRUMP OPPOSITION.
NO ONE HAS HIS SUPPORT OR
AUTHENTICITY.
YOU KNOW WHO ELSE HAS 60, 70%
PLUS DONORS.
LIZ WARREN.
LIZ AND BERNIE ARE ESSENTIALLY
THE SAME CANDIDATE WHICH MEANS
WHEN ONE DROPS OUT IT ABSORBS
THE OTHER.
>> Dana: THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO START ATTACKING EACH
OTHER.
>> Greg: I THINK ONE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO GO AWAY AND THEY
JOINED TOGETHER.
BERNIE'S PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO
GO TO JOE AND LIZ'S PEOPLE
AREN'T GOING TO GO TO JOE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A PLURALITY
OF 40%.
>> Dana: WHO WINS, JUAN?
>> Greg: I DON'T LIKE THE SHOW
ANYMORE.
>> Dana: IS COMMON SENSE
POLITICS.
>> Greg: SITTING NEXT TO YOU
FOR SO LONG, DANA, I HAVE
ABSORBED IT.
>> Dana: IS NEUTRAL, JUAN,
ELIZABETH WARREN AT SOME POINT,
AND BERNIE SANDERS, SOMEONE'S
GONNA HAVE TO JOIN THE
FIGHT.
>> Juan: THE FLIGHT HAS BEEN
GOING ON.
IT DOESN'T BENEFIT EITHER OF
THEM TO ATTACK THE OTHER.
YOU DON'T WANT TO ALIENATE
PEOPLE YOU WANT TO COME TO YOUR
SIDE.
THE FACT IS ELIZABETH WARREN IS
CLEARLY THE PERSON WITH
MOMENTUM.
THIS HAS BEEN CLEAR FOR A LONG
TIME, AND BERNIE SANDERS WHO IS
CARPING EVEN ABOUT THE LIBERAL
PRESS IS THE ONE WHO IS
FOLLOWING.
PART OF THIS IS, AS I SAID
BEFORE, FEELS LIKE I'VE SAID
THIS MOVIE BEFORE WHEN IT COMES
TO BERNIE.
I'VE SEEN A LOT OF THE RHETORIC,
THE ATTACKS.
DOESN'T HAVE ANY FRESHNESS.
ELIZABETH WARREN WITH HER IDEAS,
A SOLUTION, PLAN, HER ENERGY,
IT'S BEEN SOMETHING.
RIGHT NOW IF ALL THE BAD NEWS
WE'VE SEEN ON THE STOCK MARKET
TODAY, THE DOW WAS DOWN --
>> Dana: JUST ONE DAY.
>> Juan: OVER THE LAST THREE
WEEKS THE DOW HAS LOST 7%.
WHEN YOU FACTOR IN THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE A HIGHER AWARENESS
OF THE NATION'S ECONOMY AND ITS
IMPACT, SUDDENLY
ELIZABETH WARREN AND ALL THAT
SHE SAID ABOUT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS, RATING AND
WALL STREET, DON'T LET THE BIG
GUYS SAVIOR TOO BIG TO FAIL, IT
HAS NEW APPLICATIONS.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT WESTERN
PENNSYLVANIA?
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT THERE FOR
REASON.
HE NEEDS PENNSYLVANIA TO STAY
RED AND IN THE LAST DEBATE
JOE BIDEN SAID HE WOULD GET RID
OF FOSSIL FUELS IN TEN YEARS.
>> Jesse: REALLY DUMB COMMENT
FROM SLEEPY JOE.
THE AMERICAN WORKER HAS SHIFTED
FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY UNDER TRUMP.
TRUMP'S FOCUS ON TRADE,
IMMIGRATION, ENERGY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE CAPITULATED
ON ALL THOSE THINGS.
YOU THINK ABOUT AMERICA FIRST OR
MADE IN AMERICA AND THE ATTACK
ON THAT AND THE ATTACK ON CHINA.
THAT KIND OF ECONOMIC
NATIONALISM HAS REALLY
GALVANIZED WAGE GROWTH AND
REALLY SEEN AN EXPLOSION IN
MANUFACTURING THIS COUNTRY
THAT'S FOCUSED ON U.S. STEEL,
U.S. AUTOS, AND EVEN UNIONS HAVE
PEELED AWAY THAT SUPPORT FROM
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
DEMOCRATS WERE CAUGHT TOTALLY
FLAT-FOOTED IN 2016 AND NOW THEY
ARE PLAYING DEFENSE OF THEIR OWN
RUST BELT.
ON THE BORDER, TRUMP HAS
PROTECTED THE AMERICAN WORKER
FROM CHEAP LABOR THAT DRIVES
THOSE WAGES DOWN AND STEALS
AMERICAN JOBS AND THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE DECIDED TO SIDE WITH
FOREIGN WORKERS AND AGAINST THE
AMERICAN WORKER AND THE AMERICAN
WORKER DOES NOT LIKE THAT.
TRUMP'S FOCUS ON AMERICAN ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, ENERGY DOMINANCE.
TALKING ABOUT REESTABLISHING
DRILLING AND EXPLOITATION FOR
NATURAL GAS AND REEMERGING:
WEST VIRGINIA.
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE,
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID OKAY, WE
ARE GOING TO GET RID OF COAL AND
OIL AND GAS AND THAT WOULD
DESTROY THE U.S. ECONOMY.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE TRUMP SOME
CREDIT BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO
BLAME THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Juan: LET ME QUICKLY REBUT
IT.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN'T DO IT
QUICKLY.
>> Juan: IN THE MIDTERMS, THE
DEMOCRATS WON.
THEY WON BY SAYING WE STAND FOR
YOU.
TRUMP GOES TO THAT PLANT.
WHEN SHELL SAID THEY WERE GOING
TO BUILD THAT PLANT, 2121 BARACK
OBAMA --
>> Jesse: YOU'VE SEEN JOBS IN
THAT SECTOR GO UP BY 5,000.
>> Dana: EMILY TO SPEAK.
>> Emily: THANK YOU.
I HAD A POINT ABOUT THE SHOW
PLANT.
IT'S A UNIQUE PART OF THE
COUNTRY.
STALWART REPUBLICANS LIKE
RONALD REAGAN AND BOTH BUSH
PRESIDENTS.
McCAIN SECURED IT FOR THE
G.O.P., NOT BECAUSE HE WAS
LIKABLE BECAUSE THE POLICY WAS
RUNNING AGAINST WERE SO LIBERAL.
REPUBLICANS WINNING BY
INCREASING MARGINS THERE.
I THINK NO BIDEN OVER ANYONE
ELSE IS THE ONLY DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE THAT ACTUALLY HAS A